my name is killing Macklemore organizer
co-organizer for you betrayed our dog
mr. pickle's was on Facebook
back in October 2012 we decided that we
wanted to meet some Facebook dogs in
person and their owners so the first one
that we had we had about 12 40s here and
then we decided to do another one in 75
40 showed up then it was 250 300 400 and
today it's probably close to 600 maybe
I didn't think it would grow this big
but I'm definitely thinking it's gonna
get it even bigger than this this is her
first time at the beach she's not
digging the water but she loves the fans
I met Winston the white Corgi who I do
follow and that was pretty exciting he
keeps coming over to drink our water my
name is Tina and I'm the proud mom of
Winston the white Corgi right here
there's a lot of people who love him
obviously but all he wants to do is play
fetch we're just trying to like have a
blast and make sure we say hi to
everyone and it's fun kind of
overwhelming for him he made me carry
him from the car on my way she's a puppy
she's about four months old we've been
here for about three hours and she was
done after an hour these are my two
corgis they're wearing left with the
shark and right shark costumes we are
one of the original 12 corgis that were
here in October 2012 today their dress
has Mexican Mutola rez is our dog
carrots you just been a very athletic
dog eventually they're into last of all
whoo there's no
what does the world love about court use
so much
they're great companions are
good-looking dogs they're fun they're
intelligent you're loving she cuddles
she'll talk to you
you have the stumpy legs and they run
around and fall over things easily
because they're so small and their
tongues always hanging out so they're
kind of entertaining just to watch on
their own let me jump in the air the
bottom part say all about them you know
saying the only thing about them is they
said you know I've had probably 10
different breeds of dogs and I keep
coming back to the core game and Suzanne
from Queens best jumper dog rescue more
rescue that specializes in 1440 news
there are plenty of purebred courtiers
that need homes to the date we place
about 30 dogs
we love